hey it's hannah elliott with bloomberg
pursuits and we're here with the new
rolls-royce phantom drophead coupe my
favorite car this year at the New York
Auto Show is the 2016 rolls-royce
phantom drophead coupe yes it's big and
heavy and bold get a load of that red
interior but it's beautiful the car is
meant to showcase rolls is popular and
profitable bespoke program which
services its owners and pretty much
whatever automotive fantasy they can
imagine this one for instance has a
specialized gunmetal gray exterior with
dark crimson leather splashed all over
the seats doors and steering wheel the
seatbelts are a special shade of
grenadine and the Spirit of Ecstasy hood
ornament is illuminated from the bottom
to show off the perfect arc of its wings
inside it has stainless steel pin stripe
detailing stark white face instrument
dials and stylish 21-inch wheels even
the door side umbrellas are color
coordinated with the hand stitched
interior and black lambs wool carpeting
the rolls-royce badges inlaid in the
doors light up at night and the one on
the dash is made from solid silver it's
a lot of work to put into one car
expected to cost five hundred and sixty
thousand dollars but it's worth it
executives at rolls tell me that
ninety-five percent of all their
customers get their cars bespoke as for
me I might take this one just the way it
is